>>> TOGHT, THE UNITED STATES
IS IN THE MIDST OF AN TREME
WEATHER NIGHTME, WITH RECORD
HEAT, FIRES AND SEVERE FLOODING.
BRIAN TODD IS WORKING THE STORY
FOR US, EVERY REGION OF THE
COUNTRY SEEMS AFFECTED IN SOME
WAY.
>> EVERY CORNER OF THE LOWER 48,
ON ONE EXTREME, OFFICIALS SAY 40
ACTIVE WILDFIRES BURNT MORE THAN
A MILLION ACRES IN SIX STATES.
ON THE OTHER, HISTORICAL
RAINFALL AND SNOW MELTING
DEALING A CRIPPLING BLOW TO
ICONIC LANDMARK.
>> Reporter: A LARGE HOUSE
CRUMBLES INTO THE SURGING
YELLOWSTONE RIVER AND WASHES
DOWNSTREAM.
THE TOWN OF GARDENER, MONTANA
WHERE THAT HOUSE WAS, LEFT
ISOLATED, SURROUND SAID BY WATER
ACCORDING TO OFFICIALS WITH
SWIFT WATER RESCUES TAKING
PLACE.
HEAVY RAIN AND MELTING SNOW
CAUSED FLOODING IN YELLOWSTONE
NATIONAL PARK WHICH HAD TO BE
EVACUATED, ROADS AND BRIDGES
WASHED AWAY.
PARENTS OF CNN SUPERVISING
PRODUCER TIM CARTER TOLD US OF
THEIR NAIL-BITING TRIP OUT OF
YELLOWSTONE OVER A BRIDGE THAT
WAS COMPROMISED.
>> WHEN WE WERE GOING OUT OF IT,
IT WAS REALLY SCARY BECAUSE THE
WATER WAS ALREADY VIOLENTLY, YOU
KNOW, SWIRLING AROUND THE
BRIDGE.
SO WE DID FIND OUT LATER THAT IT
HAD WASHED OUT.
>> Reporter: BUT THE YELLOWSTONE
REGION IS NOT ALONE.
SEVERAL AREAS OF AMERICA'S LOWER
48 STATES ARE EXPERIENCING
EXTREME WEATHER, BETWEEN
INESCAPABLE HEAT, FLOODS, HEAVY
STORMS AND TORNADOS.
MORE THAN 1/3 OF AMERICANS, 125
MILLION PEOPLE ARE UNDER HEAT
ALERTS FROM NORTH CAROLINA
THROUGH THE PLAINS STATES, DUE
TO A SO-CALLED HEAT DOME THAT
PARKED ITSELF OVER THE TENNESSEE
VALLEY.
A PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIAL IN
HOUSTON SAYS NO ONE IN THESE
AREAS SHOULD SHRUG OFF THE
RISKS.
>> WHEN YOU HAVE EXTREME HEAT,
THEN EVERYONE IS IN DANGER.
WHEN YOU SUFFER HEAT EXHAUSTION
OR HEAT STROKE, THEN YOUR VITAL
ORGANS, YOUR BRAIN SUFFERS
DAMAGES AND YOU COULD DIE.
>> Reporter: AT ONE POINT IN THE
PAST 48 HOURS, MORE THAN HALF A
MILLION HOUSEHOLDS IN THE UPPER
U.S. LOST POWER AS RESIDENTS
DEALT WITH CRIPPLING HEAT IN
THOSE AREAS.
VIOLENT THUNDERSTORMS IN THE
MIDWEST DEALT SEVERE DAMAGE AND
PROMPTED TORNADO WARNINGS IN
CHICAGO.
IN THE WEST AND SOUTH WEST,
RECORD-BREAKING TEMPERATURES
COMBINED WITH HIGH WINDS, LOW
HUMIDITY AND DROUGHT ARE FUELING
WILDFIRES.
THE PIPELINE FIRE NEAR FLAG
STAFF, ARIZONA, GROWN NEAR TO
20,000 MONTANA TOWN
NEAR YELLOWSTONE CAN ONLY HOPE
HER NEW HOME SURVIVED THE
FLOODING.
>> HUSBAND AND I JUST PUT IN A
BRAND NEW HOUSE, NEVER BEEN ABLE
TO AFFORD A NEW HOUSE, IT'S
SITTING AT THE TOP OF THE LANE
AND HOPING BY SOME GOD MIRACLE
OUR HOUSE WILL BE THERE.
>> THIS PARTICULAR PATTERN OF
EXTREME WEATHER IS EXPECTED TO
LAST AT LEAST THE NEXT FEW DAYS
AND BEYOND THAT, NOT A LOT OF
RELIEF.
OUR EXPERTS AT THE CNN WEATHER
CENTER SAY BECAUSE OF CLIMATE
CHANGE, HEAT WAVES LIKE THIS ONE
ARE GOING TO BECOME INCREASING